Let's start by calculating the final kinetic energy using mgh for the gravitational potential energy.
Once again we start with conservation of energy.
The idea that the kinetic energy and the potential energy always add up to the same value
no matter what point we're at in our experiment.
Now, we know that the ball starts off with no initial velocity.
We can say that the initial kinetic energy is 0.
And we know that the ball lands on the ground at height 0, so the final potential energy is also 0.
This gives us that the final kinetic energy is just equal to the original potential energy
which is equal to mgh and plugging in the values 50 m, 9.8 m/s², and 1 kg,
we get that the final kinetic energy is 490 J.
Now let's repeat that calculation except this time we'll use
the more general formula for gravitational potential energy.
Once again we start with conservation of energy.
And just like last time, the initial kinetic energy is 0.
Now this time, we can't say that the final potential energy is 0
because our formula is slightly different.
In fact, this formula is only ever equal to 0 when R gets really, really, really, really, really, really light.
And that's not going to happen any time in our problem.
We can't ever say that the potential energy is 0.
But we can still do the math and solving for final kinetic energy
we get that the difference between the original potential energy and the final potential energy.
And we can now plug in our formula for those to get this equation.
And inserting our known values into this equation, we get that the final kinetic energy
using this version of the gravitational potential energy is 486 J.
Not bad. That's actually quite close to 490.
And using these values to calculate the percent error,
I get that my percent error for the final kinetic energy is 0.76%.
That's not bad at all. So really mgh is pretty good for calculating gravitational potential energy
over distances like 50 m but as we'll see later if we need to do much larger distances
we'll have to use this version of gravitational potential energy.